what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation greg here today as of this moment of
filming this i am still quarantining even
though i'm feeling so much better i did take
a rapid yep definitely still got the vid diesel
with that be catching up on some movies here i
feel like that's just a great way to to make
the most of it and i just want to say really
fast i've really been enjoying doing you
know like these movie reaction reviews
catching up on films i've never seen before leave
some recommendations down in the comments below
uh i just really like the format of this you
know it's like it's not too much different
than doing a show but you know to be able to do
like an instant spoiler review and then share
my experience of watching a movie that many of you
have already seen it's just so fun and enjoyable
so thank you for for being here and since a lot of
this has been catch up based off recommendations
that you guys have been throwing my way um i
figured why not mix it up a little bit i haven't
done a horror movie in a while so let's watch
the movie sinister today don't anything about
it don't know any details other than ethan hawk
is in this scott derricks and directed film but
in terms of plot no nothing i have actually a big
affinity for horror and i know this is actually
quite quite a blood film i think beloved i'm
not sure people like it oh yeah leave a like
that also be great and subscribe to become
a citizen of the reject nation and fooling
through reaction watch alongs where you sync
up with your own copy for sinister or over at
our patreon page for super sexy rejects cover a
whole bunch of stuff over there some exclusive
content as well lastly the team of prepper
thank you for helping me edit down these
highlights you guys have been an absolute
blessing as of late so let's get to it guys
that's an opening shot
oh that's freaking eerie oh man
opening image established tone
mood good we are a messed up movie
no i had to move here the new story i'm writing
is here i miss my school all right you know what
the school here is supposed to be
pretty great but i want my old one
if we don't like it here once i sell my book
we'll move back but only if we don't like it here
what the [__] is she drawing we didn't move
in a few houses down from a crime scene again
did we tracy no just don't say anything
i if we did i don't want to know about it
did you guys move into a crime scene promise i
promise oh my god you moved into a murder house
oh it's the tree where the people
were hanging you gotta be kidding me
family hanging out 11. oh that's in poor taste
that's important unless there's actually family
hanging out yes i'm listening let's at
least make sure your office stays locked
it's one thing to hear about it it's another thing
to see it i don't want him walking in again he's
12 years old mom he knows how old i am hey stop it
i forgot how old you were always lock dad's office
that's right and i don't want to hear another
thing about why we're here from anybody yeah i
predict someone will go into dad's office and it
will be unlocked if this goes sour like last time
i'll take trevor and ashley and go back home
to my sisters but it's not going to go sour
good kicks in love all right show a little
bit of like positive reinforcement now
ethan hawk just seems like
one of the coolest dudes
wow you figured out fast i'd be
spending like an hour and a half
did people back then find eight
millimeter footage creepy too
oh [__] see it is hanging out with the family
wait so that's seems like
such a dumbass that's a family
oh god i hope this doesn't become like a
shining thing where his family ends up there
that is a good question
did i miss a line about them not
getting electricity in this home
daddy i can't find the bathroom
look at all these new paintings you're really
getting good maybe one day i'll paint something
really good then i'll be famous like you you
don't want to be famous the way he's famous
how crazy would it be if ethan
hawk was playing that guy too
what the [__] these are like
a whole bunch of snuff videos
oh my goodness
you know in some ways he really
stumbled onto a gold mine here
king county police department
how may i direct your call
how may direct your call
hello oh damn it you had an
opportunity to make a right choice
but you want that 15 minutes of fame hawk
ashley
that is very noticeable
whoa it's his son
what the hell
oh my god
hey wake up come on come on come on wake
up yeah that was a hell of a frantic shot
why are we outside all right okay we're having
a bad dream okay one of those night terrors it's
just the stress of the move i found them in one of
the one of the moving boxes what a very specific
way to have night terrors i'm just really sorry
it's not your fault come on it's cold that's good
for some reason i really felt that apology
oh man dude call the cops
this person left the box there
how icky
i got some [__] up videotapes
weird
oh man that's unfortunate
man and he can't you can't just like
talk to his wife about this [__] either
your son is acting out again all right what
did he do oh so you're automatically taking
herself stop it what did you do i drew a picture
he drew a picture with a permanent marker on the
classroom whiteboard tell him what you do i
drew a tree with four people hanging from it
oh no nothing about what happened to these people
is okay but bad things happen to good people and
they still need to have their story told they
deserve that much you're a real man of the people
trying to spin it like he's
trying to do a good deed
it's like this whole movie's just him
watching an anthology of super 8 films
don't kill the dog
dude i don't think you're cut out for this
job he seems way too affected by everything
uh oh jack torrance on our hands
i gotta say i really like ethan
hawk's performance in this so far
there's actually quite a lot of
layers to his character already
what what does it say
police have released this
photo of christopher miller
the missing 13-year-old son of william and
penny miller the millers along with their
younger son were found stabbed inside their
home you get the [__] out of this house man
serial killer watcher he's being watched
again the electricity in this house
dude i'd be so paranoid
getting anxiety enough as it is
was this movie shot on film
it kind of looks that way
you are a brave brave soul man
i actually really liked it how extreme or that
what
that is like some devil [__]
family hanging out pool party
sleepy time
don't just leave that here man take it with you
yikes
well the bleeding stopped for now but if it
starts again or there's any more swelling i
want you to call a doctor immediately thank
you appreciate it i've noticed he has never
left this house i'm guessing that you got
squirrels i bet that they got spooked from the
sound of everything shutting down at once you know
they are not really i'm not really a squirrel guy
oh i am i did kill a scorpion when we first
moved in here though so maybe i should get
an exterminator scorpions have feet but
you wouldn't hear him like you would
1998 st louis a family was stabbed to
death actually they had their throats cut
in 1979 a family was burned alive parked
inside their own car in their own garage
what city i don't know all i have is a year in the
method of execution this guy's like deputy dewey
so ultimately what feels better seeing justice
done or seeing your your book kentucky blood
number one on the new york times bestseller list
the justice and without question is that the truth
good catch oh looks like an alien
at least the clues are just being
laid out for you crystal clear
so we have to make it just right
he's very particular about his coffee
i'm really capturing the way this coffee's made
2976 piedmont way st louis that is excellent two
nines wait did you say two nine seven six like
29.76 yeah why does that mean something to you
uh no no it doesn't no thank you thank you
deputy just keep looking at that image we
inverted moves moved here they lived where
the miller family murders happened holy [__]
good old spooky fun spooky fun
holy moly that is creepy
the gifts are coming for you don't just brush
that off i would get a second eye on that
make sure like you see what i'm saying
oh god you need a therapist keep wondering if he's
like already dead and he's in some weird purgatory
are you slowly giving life to this thing
yikesy
oh i found him outside we have to put a buck
in his door it's way worse than it was i'll
call the doctor in the morning i used to
stay with him i left something outside
well that is just spooky as
don't want to hurt [__]
i just want to get my bad
drop the book we can pack up get out of town and
never look back you know why because he's having
some night terrors more than that he's never been
this bad you've never been this bad you're talking
about less than a week and you're
already a mess it's been less than a week
oh my god i'm on her side now this could be my in
cold blood uh a movie deal uh talk show circuit
right the national book award and more money than
we could you know we could live i don't care about
any of those everybody doesn't lose this is my
shot tracy your sin is greed if you want me to
run interference for you while you get this worked
out i got to be in the loop just a little bit
you really want to help it's my home it's
rothful what happened here happened to all of us
they both got that like uh conflicting shadow
thing i don't know it's just like being consumed
by the darkness you think these are serial murders
maybe more ritualized than necessarily serial but
really spread out and not just regionally but over
time the first one i found dates back to the 60s
the 1960s
in each instance the killer murdered
the entire family except one
a child which he took with him you might want to
call the university there's a professor over there
professor jonas he's an occult crime expert and
the state police bring him in on some of the app
the weirder stuff i don't want
that cop to die he seems so sweet
i like the the plays of shutter speed it's
like you have a different kind of camera use
for the transitions into a different camera lens
you're about to see a pov through it's pretty cool
so where's this little girl now if you find
yourself trying to figure out the mystery dude
it's the goddamn devil
he murdered the lawnmower
that was just a combination of
all sentences that are there
that's actually i really like
that jump scare because it's so
hypnotic with the music and the visuals
it was getting like entranced in it then
it felt like my chest just tied in so much there
thank you for getting back to me so quickly i
appreciate that uh of course i'm a a really big
fan i'm flattered that you thank you once i saw
the photos that you said i knew exactly what cases
that you were studying wait how kingpin are their
hero it's a symbol associated with the worship of
a pagan deity a deity what kind of deity a a very
obscure one dating back to babylonian times named
bagool the eater of children did you say eater
he looks so frightened each story involves a
a different way that he lures or tricks these
children away from the physical world and
of course the few times that this symbol has
shown up none of the crimes have been related
in any way to any of this and so this might be
more of a cult initiation rather than you know the
actual actions of any one man sure that's better
what the [__]
dude move
i like the way the little girl ghost plays
creepy
i'm assuming they're the kids that were hung
all right let's have some specific markings
so i'd say you can hear it's an
interesting choice let you see the ghosts
oh my god oh my god no no
no no no no that poor girl
i am not a fan of that uh i'm an
offender it's good it's good scary [__]
that's like the first time we really
broke perspective from ethan hawk
these are more fun to watch with
you guys than just me by myself
so i appreciate you coming by officer oh
yes it's not a problem at all so we're we're
becoming friends right i mean i suppose yeah
i mean i can trust you right yeah absolutely
lose my [__] mind okay well does your wife know
about it does she know whose house this is was
oh man oh that is a conversation
that i would not want to be around
here here there was none of that uh with the
stevenson son no in the shortest amount of
time that the stevenson's lived here they
never called the police they never had the
police called on them or reported anything
bizarre that came up in the investigation
you know i was so good at this i like this
cop a lot too there's a whiskey bottle in your
office that doesn't appear to be the slightest
neglected mrs all right mr oswald miss roswell
listen i don't i don't i'm not saying that you
have a drinking problem okay i don't think that
nor do i think that you're making any of this
up no to get attention i don't think that
this is such a good scene work i
thought something was in the house
and i woke up on the couch holding a baseball
bat if you sleep in this house it's just gonna
do terrible things to your head yeah man you don't
need to be here you have a second house you can
move back to paint only goes in the bedroom what
makes you think you can paint out here i wanted
to paint her picture but she didn't want it in my
room because that used to be her brother's room
what she's the one daddy's writing his book about
actually go to your room and shut the door that
conversation's about to happen i really do think
it's cool they let you see that the little girl
did experience the ghost like they actually
showed you that we never should have come here
nobody died here okay it's not like we're sleeping
where somebody was killed it's not like they had
to wipe blood off the walls for the opening it
didn't happen here no it happened in the backyard
i think that makes a difference
no ellison it doesn't
the kind of jeopardy you put your children in
your marriage yes i do i understand what you
won't do for your goddamn book i guess this is
all worth it to you what's worth it putting your
family at risk what risk of what of more
paintings don't oh my god mr minimizer
man there are plenty of other ways you
can provide for this fight during what
don't you understand that writing is what gives
my life meaning these books are are my legacy
man this is such a cautionary tale you and me
right here this marriage that's the meaning
of your life and your legacy that's ashley and
trevor your kids are your legacy this is true
what the [__]
no he's starting to be recorded
all right it's eight millimeter
footage of the ladder
so you can see all this right you can see the kids
see like the wife would have heard all that
right like the clashing on the ground i made a
mistake we should have never come to this house we
have to leave now oh you're freaking me out here
get the kids pack the car we have to
leave are they gonna be able to leave
hey he's out of the house
there goes all my theories
where are we going daddy we're going home honey
oh great
they did talk about getting pulled over at the
beginning of this movie i don't want to be reading
in your book that angry town folks chased you out
of here there isn't going to be any bug just one
more favor hold it under 60 till you cross the
county line and do you somebody else's problem
i ain't fun for any of this [__]
no the terror has followed they used
to live there now they live here
right isn't that the trajectory
of like they used to live there
maybe people did i don't know
i don't i can't figure this out
it's like what is it what's the goddamn reveal
bagola actually lived in the images themselves
and that they were gateways into his realm
the ancient church believed that he would take
possession of those who saw the images and caused
them to do terrible things your call came so late
answer
man to hell with addicts
oh my god
extended cut endings
oh man that is mean call the cop back
that cop has some answer for you man
the dates the addresses each family that you
had me look up had previously lived in the
house where one of the earlier murders took place
exactly but before the miller family was killed
the millers lived in the same house in orange
county where the delusional lawn massacre kurt
if this guy is still out there you
not only just sped up his timeline
you put yourself in it it's like they shoves
you out of the house and that's the final step
oh my god
put this on your cell phone
that is creepy as hell stephanie
oh they gotta compile it all to one
your daughter or your son could be either
one of them you gotta kill them both
no no
holy [__] don't worry daddy
i'll make you famous again
it's oh some tails from the [__] kind of
oh my god
it's crazy the little girl on the poster
oh that's terrible man
huh
she just jumps in the frame
yeah it was like uh tales from the crypt
nice one not bad i enjoyed
the hell out of that one
i heard the sequel's not as good
what is it just like lore exploration
was great that was great gotta got some thoughts
that i definitely want to dive into and just
wait to see if there's a post credit scene okay
ladies and gentlemen i am not going to [__] you
uh in between stopping the movie
i went to go to the bathroom
i was like a kid again i went to the bathroom
and then the second i stepped out of this door
it's just this pitch-black hallway it's
like it's it's 3 26 a.m right now this is
this pitch black hallway and i could see
into another room and it was pitch black
and i was legit scared i i kept thinking
i was gonna see mr buggy and then i went
to the bathroom and the window was open and i
was like oh god damn it's happening to me great
great that means it's effective it's uh yeah
you know i i liked it i liked it a lot i thought
i think there's a lot of great qualities about
this film i like that it has this like cool blend
of true crime with this undercurrent of
like a percolating supernatural horror
as well it's got this really cool mix of both
you know and as someone who is is very much
interested in both of those genres and uh very
a fan i would say it was cool to see a story
that really blended both while also hearkening
to works of stephen king and then also hearkening
to you know like i really liked uh the show tales
from the crypt which i i know i mentioned a couple
of times here but those are always like cautionary
tales about usual usually it's the downfall of
someone usually is the downfall of someone doing
something terrible and then they get what's coming
to them and that's not exactly what this is
but it's still a cautionary tale of you know
watching how this like the twist the reveal of
it this bites them in the ass about how oh he's
he keeps saying he wants to be provide for the
family but he's so he's so you know motivated
by but ultimately what is like a greedy desire you
know but it's it's a very relatable desire that's
that's what i thought was really effective about
it because i think a lot of people will often be
in this situation like i thought a lot of
the arguments that were written between
him and and the wife were pretty realistic you
know i like those little moments where usually
it can be played out in a cliche way and at times
it felt like you know there was such good rhythm
to the back and forth of the dialogue with some
of these arguments that that was the one thing
that really helped it really helped save it from
becoming like frustrating or perfunctory you know
like little lines that would be thrown in there
of like i'm uh you know like yeah we gotta have
all this money it's gonna be my capote book you
know like then the name of the book too reminds
me of you know i think it's a very intentional
thing of playing on capote's cold blood book um
but when they are fighting he's like yeah do this
for all this money it's like we don't i don't care
about the money the wife says and then you know
he interjects yeah everyone does a little bit
i'm like yes that's that's that feels more real to
me as opposed to having like a bunch of dramatic
pauses in between i think the way the back and
forth is with a lot of the scene work was really
great and that helped really drive home the points
even more and actually paint a a solid gray area
for a lot of this debate you know and because
i think fleshing out the ethan hawk character
whose name i'm totally forgetting even though
i just watched this movie um i was going to
call him ethan hawk i think the combination of
the writing of ethan hawk's character of how
that is what's propelling this journey and
then of course ethan hawke's performance
really bringing that to life because you know
he hops back and forth between saying two things
which is you know like oh i want to do good i
want to save this person i want to do right i need
to solve this crime but then also he's got the
thing of blind ambition and chasing those glory
days the the al bundy days as i usually refer
to it and you know chasing those glory days and
the times where he felt adored and was wealthy
you know living the american dream and he can't
just appreciate what he has in front of him
you know there's like another version of this
movie where i could see like a guillermo del toro
story where it would have a bit more of a fairy
tale ending where he does ultimately learn the
right thing and he gets to live with his family
and and and and be happy after some glorious
supernatural um you know finale but that obviously
is not the case here that's not the kind of horror
movie this is but with the ethan hawk character
what was what was great about it was i believe
again that gray area i believe both sides you can
see that there are shades of him that obviously
really want to solve this because of his obsession
with solving the case in a time and you
could and you could see how he's not just
some cold-blooded guy when watching the found
footage qualities uh watching all the things
that were left behind for him to to dissect he's
very much affected and squeamish and and horrified
and you know because it's also watching
families and like little kids being killed
you could already pick up on the performance
without him having to say it that if he's
a father himself and of course you know he
could be flashing to his own children as well
and i i really think ethan hawk
provided both of those qualities
because his character is in conflict with himself
like while a lot of times he will lay down that it
it's like yeah about the money it's about the
money but no it's actually about this and you can
see that there is that conflict where they they
are like combating with the with each other uh
throughout at least that's the way i interpreted
it that i thought um there were times where he
really just did care about solving this and didn't
care to want to know the truth and understanding
and clearly because even he at the end he was
like i did by the time he was back at the house
he didn't want to um write a book anymore but
he but he still had to know he still had to know
the truth especially when scary ass spooky [__]
just keeps happening and of course he has to know
the truth what the hell would you when you box the
show back up in the attic and such uh so i thought
that ethan hawk absolutely killed it like the the
anguish in his performance it was very very human
and very natural and he didn't like overplay the
drama you watch this character really descend over
time like so much earlier on i could already pick
up on all these different layers because there's
such a build up to everything sort of collapsing
on itself internally and externally with with with
ethan hawk's relationship with as a dad and as a
husband and that that buildup of tension with him
and his wife because it was constantly you know
like i don't like being here ethan i don't like
being here and i i you could do something else to
provide we don't need the money and all this stuff
and then fighting and then oh i'm sorry no i love
you you know like it was it was kind of this uh
pattern that just kept building and building and
building upon itself till it was just starting to
really implode upon implode upon the two of
them and i think that there was such great
nuance handled on things that could have
just been solely tropes uh because it's in
fact sometimes i felt like they would do certain
horror motifs and tropes in order to mislead you
and make you think something else is about to
happen when it doesn't and i thought that was
there was great usage of it and i actually
really like i know when you say jump scares
there's this one pocket of the internet of the
world that like gawks at that word but i think
jump scares when utilized properly can be quite
effective and make for an exciting experience
and i thought the use of jump scares here was
also used very well and like some of them were
just truly like oh my god that was really just
like some of the jump scares would like just like
like land their claws into your soul and just
like and i really appreciated that because a
lot of times you can see jump scares coming and
even at times you could see a jump scare coming
it would be a different kind of combination
of sensory experiences that would still get
me so jolted again it was like kind of
being like electrocuted for a while just
i liked it i like i liked the way i liked
the way that was handled and i think scott
derrickson's direction here is really cool because
you know you're you're this character's picking up
you know um a super eight has a projector and
you're hopping between two different cinematic
styles which is the found footage eight millimeter
footage very creepy stuff snuff film it very
creepy um yeah that was some creepy ass [__] but
then you know once in a while i would get a little
pulled out like something's like i don't actually
know what it looks like for someone to have
their throat slit like i don't i don't actually
know what that looks like but it did still look
like cinematic cutting it looked like movie
cutting of someone's neck so it would still
kind of pull me out a little bit but that's like
my one nitpick about that level of violence like i
thought the the use of the other ways of violence
i thought were way way creepier than having the
the knife of the throat um you know like tying
them up on the pull benches and then drive on
dragging them into the into the water that was
super creepy that one really stands out to me
uh the the ones being like tied up in in the
car being on fire or even like that really
effective one with the with the lawnmower how
just cut away right away uh when it was about
to like go over the person's head like that was i
like the way that was edited thank god we didn't
actually see that that was i wouldn't i don't
know why that's not fun that's not fun at all
like this this movie managed to deal with
true crime deal with supernatural horror
while at the same time being really entertaining
and also being dreadful like it had that cool
like that blumhouse flavor where it is like a fun
horror movie still but also in that other qual
that other genre that is like considered elevated
horror where it's very it's mainly psychological
uh more than it is you know wanting to be fun
spooky horror that's about unpacking all these
these myths and lores and you do get that like
the the the reveal that's why i said it when i
was reacting to it that's why they cut to because
this whole movie's from ethan hawk's perspective
and i always take note when you break perspective
i'm very i i tend to get really caught up on
on in movies of how perspective is captured
and so when i had that one moment when it
because it starts playing with the audience
it's sorry i'm starting to get like a bunch
of thoughts that are starting to like flow in
right now um it starts playing with the audience
where yeah oh that's cool that's brilliant
i just appreciated this movie a lot more
because this movie deals so much with imagery
like you got the eight millimeter camera at the
projector then you got the way the movie actually
just looks like an uh like a modern day film
and you know you're dealing with laptops you got
a different bunch of images and screens and then
you do have that moment when mr boogie does uh
turn on in the laptop and looks at ethan hawk and
it does seem to have that there's like a word
for it what is that word damn i can't count
i can't come up with a word but the part
of the philosophy of it is is like images
you get consumed enough with images they start to
kind of like look back at you if yes i think we're
making that up i think that's a thing i've heard
about um and and then eventually you know it's
like the movie itself in its relationship with
the audience starts to look back at you as well
where it does start to kind of break the veil
and break perspective where you start to see the
creeks which are actually the ghost children they
actually the movie starts to show you the ghosts
and when ethan hawk can't see the ghosts and it
and it was a neat way to play with the horror
motif of little kids because it only enhanced the
mystery more like it had had my mind constantly
going is ethan hawk already dead is he already a
ghost that's in the dial like i was really like
kind of jumping ahead and thinking of other things
because they were messing with this trope but at
the same time it was pulling back that veil so
you know it's starting to clue the audience in by
we're watching the image of the movie and then the
image now looking back at us with the oh that's so
cool i actually really like that i mean this could
just be my wild interpretation about it but i feel
like that's what the movie's doing but the image
is looking back at us and you have uh like you see
the ghost children and then you break perspective
for the first time out of all the characters to to
then just slowly lock onto um the daughter and see
that you're interacting with the kid and giving
like some actual clues here as to you're giving
actual clues here and and and looking back i'm
like okay there are because any part of a good
twist reveal is i i like the feeling of going
oh yeah i could have put that together maybe
and because i did start to think like maybe
the little girl's grown up because you know
like the movie eventually lets you in on
it's a supernatural horror they eventually let
you know this is a supernatural horror film and
because i never i never got to the point
where i'm like is this is this all in his head
is this this real is it not real is it is it what
what is this you know it didn't actually have me
debate that and maybe the movie
didn't want you to but i feel like
kind of telling you early on like no there's some
real supernatural [__] actually happening here
and and uh and i just lost my shirt because
i got so many thoughts coming in here i
i think the way the movie yeah because it was
messing with the audience and i like the way
it it messes with the audience it starts to
become a bit of a meta experience in that
regard and the way scott derrickson messes with
the different film styles and shutter speeds
and messing with horror motifs to make you
question things and uh you know being the the
lighting uh there's the eerie lighting uh where
so much of the time characters are entering from
first being in darkness and then they enter into
light or they walk into darkness or everything is
very dark this is a very dark movie it's like
shadow eventually over consuming everyone with
some grade a acting from ethan hawk throughout
and i think the the cop deputy so and so i think
do we ever learn the cops name uh deputies so and
so uh such an earnest performance and i thought it
was gonna be like oh here we go just the the dumb
cop bunch of comedic relief jokes and then they
evolved him into something more and you do show
that he is very capable and actually smart like
you know it wasn't just uh the dummy got a job
in dumb town uh he actually shows that oh okay it
makes sense why he's a cop like he he can actually
do his job when the time comes for it um and also
him being a reflection of him being a cop himself
but also kind of wanted a little bit of that
that fame and recognition and that obsession with
true crime to a certain extent i i i think the
the mirroring of that was was really cool and i
i really appreciated him part of me wants to know
if he's in sinister too like apartment goes okay
i i i'm not i'm not itching to instantly watch
sinister 2 right away because i've i've heard that
it's not as good and uh uh but i'm like but if
he's in it i might want to check it out actually
so yeah uh he was he was a great character
the some of my little qualms uh that i would
have with the movie though do come down to as
much as i appreciated the more realistic
writing and and performance especially uh
i don't know the wife's that i don't know the
wife's character name or the actors uh but they're
like i thought the performance is over
most were really elevated i couldn't tell
if it was quite the writing or the acting
because even though there is a pretty big
realism to the repetition and the escalation of
their relationship at times uh she she would i
would find her a little frustrating uh and in term
it just started feeling like a little bit of like
trophy in the way she was ultimately written
i thought adding in a little bit more of those
nuances of like oh yeah i've calmed down i
was taking something out of you i'm sorry
does help eliminate some of that uh but there
were certain moments where i did find myself
being like a little frustrated but then again he's
the ultimate [__] and it makes sense why she
would be uh have that much tension built up in her
while they kept doing that i might take that one
back i might take that one back you know in the
immediacy of the moment i would sometimes feel it
but thinking back on it doesn't really bother me
that much what i did really crave was and i know
this is kind of common with horror movies and kind
of movies in general where the main characters
aren't kids was a little bit more fleshing out of
the children uh i wouldn't have minded an extra
like five ten minutes just to have the kids feel
like have real personalities you know it's like
the the kid boy was uh was just angsty teen or
having night terrors and it was kind of just those
two notes you know one very effective creepy note
and the yeah i was just like exciting creepy and
it's kind of like such a horror movie thing and
then the little girl was like i'm a little girl
you know not that no not real personalities to
them and and i could i re especially with seeing
who the personalities are of these parents
and how involved they are with their kids
i i did find myself going like uh i would probably
care just that much more about even though i'm
really emotionally invested and i really care
uh about like the about it's like i don't want
the family to die i just don't want them to
die i'm really invested in ethan hawk i i did
go oh that would have just pushed this movie up
that much more if the kids were ridden better and
and i think it would have made the the the twist
that much more effective because it does feel
like horror movie kid at the end you know it's a
little it's a little goofy which is like writing
uh or drawing it's a little goofy but it would
have made it that much more effective i thought
if if they if they have more meat to the writing
of them another thing that i want to credit to
is the score there was that great pulsating like
throbbing uh electronic way to it where at times
it would just sound like uh like just this shrill
sound effect instead of instrument and i i think
i think that was really cool to kind of have this
like weird sensory meditative experience with it
where at times you couldn't tell if it was music
or if it was just like [__] painstaking sounds
uh that was great great stuff and yeah the you
know the the i i think the cautionary tale of
of this element really rides more on how he
should have he shouldn't have done this and
he did like some messed up things like i think
that's pretty messed up to move your family into
a murder house knowing god damn well it's a
murder house uh that's pretty messed up and
and then and all the warning signs about you
should just go to the cops or you should just put
this down generally just wouldn't listen and and
because you kept pursuing things that ultimately
would not bring him or his family happiness and
and that's a good life lesson there's also that
horror movie cautionary tale thing of uh you know
don't touch things that don't [__] belong to you
you know that'd be thinking that
way because when i moved here
there was some stuff left behind and i
was like ooh i kind of want to just go
through it you know like male gets delivered
here i'm like i kind of want to open it
that juju could come from that you know what
i mean um but yeah uh i i think that overall
this was a very effective horror movie and it
was ex it was exciting i was thoroughly engaged
and i started this at like 12 45
at night or something like that
and i got the video right now but yet i feel i was
wide awake for it and had a really good time and
it it it had more nuance to it and some cool
themes that i just wasn't expecting i didn't
know what to expect out of it but the package
that i got i thought is a really cool package
and this is one of the best ethan hawk
performances i've ever seen i've seen i
haven't seen like a ton of ethan hawk movies
and generally i think he's a great actor but
this performance here i thought was really great
so yeah thank you guys for being here this was
a hell of a ride and before i go i would like
to end this with a patron of the day shout out
tyler hague tyler the reason i'm shouting you out
is because if i was stuck in just a terrifying
horror situation where i couldn't leave a house
who would i want to be cozied up with is you we
call you our cuddle bearer the patreon for
a reason so if i was in a horrific situation
i needed to feel safe if i just needed to feel
protected and to know in here that everything's
gonna be okay i'd snuggle up with you you'd
hold me and keep me warm and then if you had to
you just hold me into your belly like in
gladiator and then just press my mouth into you
and then you put me out of my
misery which should be the ultimate
relief so tyler i love that
you're willing to kill me if
tyler you're the man dude uh you're absolutely
right i should just say that you're the best
and and uh i miss hearing from you but you've
never left my mind and so because you're no g
and you're loyal as [__] and i'm so curious to
know what you have been up to lately actually i'm
gonna send you a message i'm so curious to know
what you've been up to it's been it's been such
a long time playing any new video games how's that
book coming along does that book come a long time
i'm delirious see buddy